our network tbs was in the news recently
and i'm sorry to say it was in a pretty
unfavorable light you see last weekend
tbs aired the holiday classic movie
jingle all the way
and then they completely cut out the
movie's ending
enraging jingle fans everywhere
yes people were really really angry
now trust me i know how much jingle all
the way means
to so many millions of people so here's
what i did i used my
celebrity influence at tbs and i asked
permission to air the unedited
ending of jingle all the way on our show
i thought that would be a nice way to
make amends with the public
well guess what no one at tbs returned
any of my calls
so i'm gonna take that as a yes so here
for all you fans is the jingle all the
way ending
you missed
join me
thanks turbo man i knew you'd save me
you can always comment well
listen up and don't be late well i tell
you all the story of
jingle all the way arnold plays the dad
some kid plays a son then they both blew
up
now the story is done that's it that's
all don't believe the rumors i said they
both exploded it's not a
tumor
[Music]
i remember that ending was controversial
yeah at the time
yeah yeah it made a lot of kids cry yeah